Громада села Мотижин Київської області пережила окупацію російських військ.
Мотижинці стали свідками вбивств односельчан, зокрема старости села і її родини.
Через місяць після деокупації громада села почала вимагати переходу її церкви - з підпорядкування Московського патріархату до ПЦУ.
Як приносити панахиду за убієнних у Московську церкву? Це ж.. Це ж нонсенс, розумієте?
А тепер - українська, наша церква, можна йти, молитися. Кажуть, Бог один. Так, Бог один, але важливо й те, кому належить ця церква.
Колишній священник громади не перешкоджав приєднанню парафії до ПЦУ, однак сам служити в новій церкві відмовився.
На заміну йому прийшов новий настоятель, отець Віталій, який, власне, й узявся опікуватися процедурою переходу.
Це є суспільний і спільний біль цього села. Тут кожен один за одного переживає. Якщо не трапилося в моїй хаті, то трапилося у сусіда.
Як ми можемо після цього молитися московській церкві? Якби ж патріарх Кирил не благословляв на війну.
А він благословив. Що тут ще говорити…
Від початку війни новини про приєднання церков Московського патріархату до Православної церкви України з'являються ледь не щодня.
За три роки після Об'єднавчого Собору до ПЦУ долучилися приблизно 700 парафій. За майже три місяці повноцінної війни - вже 200 громад.
Щоправда, на думку теолога Олександра Єфременка, кількість переходів могла бути ще більшою. На заваді стають два аспекти - юридичний і психологічний.
Хоча кожна парафія - це окрема юридична особа, в документах можуть бути зачіпки, які дають право єпархіям на майно громад, зокрема на будівлю храму.
Не завжди майно парафії належить самій громаді, громада далеко не завжди на початковому етапі свого становлення мала юристів, адвокатів,
мала можливість все юридично забезпечити, зокрема в майновому сегменті життя громади.
Буває таке дуже часто, що майно частково належить єпархії, частково є приватною власністю, частково може бути в оренді, тобто факторів дуже багато.
Відповідно не кожна парафія має ресурси і зв'язки, щоб вступати з єпархіями УПЦ МП в юридичні суперечки.
Водночас, на думку Єфременка, зволікання з переходами до ПЦУ мають також психологічне підґрунтя.
По-перше, в Московському патріархаті традиційно панує атмосфера абсолютної покори.
І по-друге, серед священнослужителів МП системно розповсюджувалися думки щодо неканонічності Православної церкви України.
Демонізація автокефального руху з політичних міркувань, але загорнуті в релігійну обгортку,
відбувалися протягом усього періоду існування Київського патріархату, становлення ПЦУ.
Всі, хто хотіли допомогти чи сприяли встановленню помісної церкви в Україні, вони були як мінімум названі єретиками.
Тим часом громадський тиск на УПЦ Московського патріархату зростає.
Деякі священники під час богослужінь досі моляться за здоров’я патріарха Кирила, який благословив російських військових на війну проти України.
Інших церковників МП звинувачують в колаборантстві. Наприклад, жителі Бородянки розповідають,
що місцевий священник виводив до російських солдатів мирних мешканців і допомагав організувати штаб окупантів.
Олії у вогонь додала і нещодавня заява синоду УПЦ МП, у якій зазначається, що діяльність попередньої влади на чолі з Порошенком
і томос стали одним із приводів військового вторгнення в Україну.
Після чого ПЦУ закликала глав УПЦ МП "оговтатися від московського дурману".
А низка храмів, зокрема один з найбільших храмів Луцька - Свято-Благовіщенський - після такої заяви синоду
заявили про вихід з УПЦ та приєднання до ПЦУ.
На думку релігієзнавця Ігоря Козловського, попри такі заяви сприймати УПЦ МП як однорідну структуру не можна.
Митрополії і єпархії мають міцніший зв'язок з Росією, ніж самі парафії.
УПЦ МП - це не є моноліт. З одного боку, перед державою, громадянським суспільством,
активною частиною самої церкви, маю на увазі низові парафії і священників на місцях, стає завдання відірватися від Москви, тобто від'єднатися від РПЦ.
А єпископати не поспішають це робити, і більше того, таке враження, що вони і не збираються цього робити.
Разом з тим деякі парафії УПЦ МП, засуджуючи Кирила, все одно не готові приєднатися до ПЦУ.
Вони хочуть зберегти свою церкву, але при цьому від'єднатися від Російської православної церкви.
Є ще один рух - це підписанти листа до Собору давніх східних церков, до Пентархії, з проханням суду над патріархом Кирилом,
і визнати ідеологію "руського миру" як єресь.
Це інша позиція, інший пошук виходу із ситуації, мовляв, вони також проукраїнські, але не хотіли б приєднатися до ПЦУ.
І шукають можливість або домовитися зі Вселенським патріархом, або (отримати) окремо вікаріат або екзархат від Вселенського патріарха.
Експерти сходяться на думці, що попри потужний вплив вищих ланок УПЦ МП на парафії, ситуація буде змінюватися.
Віряни, як мінімум, будуть, так би мовити, "голосувати ногами", тобто відвідувати інші церкви, ігноруючи Московський патріархат.
Саме так, на думку мешканців Мотижина, і сталося б, якби їхній храм не змінив конфесію.
Я йому кажу: "Батюшка, ніхто не буде ходити до цієї церкви, повірте! Треба щось робити. Ви будете приходити просто один до церкви".
Так воно й було. Він приходив, а люди не йшли. А ось у нас, в суботу відбулися збори, в неділю відбулася служба (від ПЦУ), більше 50 людей прийшли...
Водночас і релігієзнавці, і священнослужителі вважають, що заборона діяльності УПЦ МП не буде ефективною.
Це лише дасть Росії ще один привід звинуватити Україну у релігійних гоніннях.
До того ж, МП має в Україні сотні парафій з тисячами прихожан, і заборонити їхнє існування не буде демократичним рішенням ситуації.
Тож, державі й церковникам доведеться шукати мирне врегулювання проблеми,
можливо, звернувшись до третьої сторони - Вселенського патріарха, який вже допоміг українцям в отриманні томосу.